[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 70 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am Francis Campo and I'm here with my
colleague Mark Mandel hey Mark how we
doing I'm doing very well Francis how
are you doing today I'm doing pretty
good pretty good still second week of
relaxing time after next you know
feeling relaxed planning on new stuff
today we have a very cool interview that
we're rescuing from the cloud next 2017
conference floor yep we got the chance
to meet well actually I had met him
before but I don't think your metaphor
yeah so we met with Bradbury jiske who
is the creator of drom CI and we got the
chance to talk about how it works and
drone CI is for those that don't know
it's a continuous integration continuous
deployment platform that is based on
containers and since Jesse Frisell was
walking around just around we figured we
just pull her in and be like hey you
wanna come join us
yeah so she joined us so we have to then
interview with both Bradbury jiske and
just for that was pretty awesome it was
pretty awesome and once we're done with
that we've got our question of the week
all about her debuffs yeah why should we
use protocol buffers why is this thing
cool and like what is it useful for yeah
and the question is actually coming from
someone that came to meet us at the TCC
podcast booth at cloud neck so all cloud
necks related things today
exactly so before we get into our
interviews and their questions of the
week why don't we talk through our cool
things of the week yeah so the first one
that you brought is for Google cloud
dataflow which I I love it's an amazing
platform to basically do like flows of
data yeah big streaming piles of data
and doing real-time like analytics or
ETL or all sorts of other fun stuff to
it as it comes through the only thing I
didn't like is that you had to write
Java for it and I I've done it yep but
it's not the case anymore well so you
could write Python on dataflow for a
while but it is now generally available
yeah so you can go hack on that and you
have SLA DS and all the good stuff which
is pretty cool so you can build
lines on say Apache beam as well which
is the open source version of data flow
within Python as well as do them
directly on data flow until you can do
all your data needs and analytic needs
on data flow using Python under general
availability go have at it and have lots
of fun nice and there's if you're more
interested on data flow we had an
episode episode number 30 where we
talked about gaming analytics and we we
talked a little bit more in detail what
data flow is but I guess that at some
point we should do an episode we should
yeah yeah as soon as they get support
for go hello
anyway the second cool thing of the week
actually the second and the third one
are related both to sequel yeah so this
one's mine too so this is kind of cool
this was a blog post that's on the big
data and machine learning blog talking
about how you can use our I have to
think about that because in Australia
now I can't say haha I say our are the
programming language commonly used for
scientific numerical analytic
statistical data crunching and providing
plots and whatnot for the data how to
connect that up to the cloud sequel the
my sequel Edition so that you can pull
data out of your cloud sequel systems
and do statistical analysis on it
build graphs build diagrams all that
cool stuff so your data scientists can
have loads of fun with your cloud sequel
data nice I have two jokes do you know
what's the favorite language of pirates
and you know how to say are in Spanish
know everybody that's right okay so the
last cool thing of the week for today is
again cloud sequel yep but these
PostgreSQL is not my sequel as you know
we announced that doing club next and
there's a blog post written about how
you can use it for geospatial
applications and and I think it's very
interesting because it actually comes
from our friends in the card labs yeah
we have them before we had them
specifically one episode we had kin team
Kelton on episode 41 mm-hm and and they
do a lot of really cool things with maps
and now they're talking about how they
actually do these and how do they
queries about like oh how do I find
these things in map storing all the
information on PostgreSQL with cloud
sicko so it's a very interesting blog
post with a lot of really interesting
detail a lot of cool graphs and maps and
diagrams so if you're interested on
geospatial applications and specifically
sequel my sequel of PostgreSQL go check
it out
awesome well why don't we go chat with
our friends bread and Jessi and let's
see what they're up to
let's do that we're now joined by Brad
Britt deskey here on still the floor of
cloud max in Moscone West in San
Francisco beautiful California and I'm
very happy to welcome here hello Brad
how are you doing very good thank you
thanks for having me thank you for
coming why why why are you here who are
you okay yeah so I'm an open source
developer I work primarily on an open
source project called drone it focuses
on container based continuous delivery
so it integrates with Google cloud
platform and many of the many of my you
know open source community members use
Google cloud platform so it's a great
opportunity to be here and learn about
the platform cool I'm also pretty
excited and I have to admit something
I'm a huge fan of yours
we have a guest host here as well Jesse
Frizzell how are you doing I'm good
I just gave my talk so now I'm super
relaxed yeah basically we decided that
we're gonna be talking a little bit of
our containers at some point so in case
that we say anything wrong just you can
just like shout out ass or something
yeah I'm totally ok with that yep so
let's talk a little bit more about drone
you said is a continuous delivery
product or service what is it exactly
what is the difference with others like
I don't know like Travis or Jenkins sure
I think the biggest difference is that
drone is built from the ground up to use
containers as the build runtime
specifically right now it uses docker so
every single build and build step
execute in a docker container itself and
the configuration is defined as a
superset of
Kocher compose yanil so it's really a
container first solution so this project
is it open source is it hosted what's
the the idea there yeah it's completely
open source it's on github you can find
it at github comm / drone / drone
awesome and but drones also a business
as well is that correct yes so it
started out as a service where you know
a subscription service similar to a lot
of the other ones out there but right
now we focus mostly on open source and
on-premise and enterprise cool and
before we get into the details on how it
is implemented
what's the name drone the idea with the
name drone came from this idea that it
was automated that you had something
controlling and executing your your
builds in an automated fashion you know
kind of from like a central source like
that that Borg source I think that's a
name you guys are familiar with Google
you know it was also the name came like
five years ago maybe when I was a little
less of a controversial term and then it
just connect and you know domain names
are hard to come by so I just wasn't
interested in in changing at that point
so cool so let's talk a little bit more
about exactly how drone works like you
said there's an open-source project so
you can run it anywhere where are people
running it how do you run it sure will
drone is built and go so it compiles
down to a nice small binary that has no
external runtime dependencies it ships
in like a 15 megabyte docker scratch
image so it's really easy to get up and
running and you can really run it
anywhere you want on any on any cloud on
on your you know within your data center
on your own infrastructure there are
it's a really portable system now I
think we're talking about as well that
before before the episode you run it at
you most people run it on kubernetes or
a lot of people do yeah I mean I think
it's incredible you know I remember of a
year or two ago kubernetes came up
somewhat frequently I think now within
the drone community almost every day
someone is installing drone on
kubernetes
I'm blown away and I think as a result
we're spending a lot more time trying to
integrate with kubernetes and make that
a more seamless experience cool could
you tell us anything more about why
kubernetes maybe maybe Jesse knows about
this like whether you think of Ranas
would be a good environment to run such
a thing as drone yeah I think a lot of
people actually use kubernetes most of
the time for CI processes because you
have a bunch of jobs you don't really
care on which nodes they run you just
need to get it somewhere and it needs to
complete so having just like the basic
scheduler there to handle a bunch of
jobs for your corporation or something
it's super nice
I'm sure the isolations also a nice
factor too oh yeah of course because
containers isolate and then you kind of
have peace of mind that team two is not
messing with team one so whenever I
think about a bunch of different tasks
that need to be processed
especially for kubernetes the first
thing that comes to mind is the jobs API
are you using it so right now we we
initially started looking at the jobs
API and one of the suggestions we got
was instead of using the jobs API was to
create custom namespaces one for each
build and then inside that namespace
spin up pods with persistent volumes and
then for each step in the pipeline
creating a new pod so for those people
who aren't familiar and I'll defer to
you just eat what's the namespace what
does that mean yes so kubernetes has
this concept of namespaces where you can
almost segregate how your cluster is
defined in terms of where things are
running and how they run in terms of
interactions with other containers so
when you namespace something you're kind
of blocking off network traffic stuff
like that from interacting with another
namespace and we're we're even getting
to in the future is where your security
model could be the namespace as a
boundary which is why it would actually
be great for drone in this case because
then maybe even multi-tenant jobs not in
the same company could be run on
kubernetes
see I which would be really cool so
basically you could say that is kind of
like a one more name one more layer of
insulation like containers providing
levers layer of insulation namespaces is
like a second one more time yeah it's
just the more abstract layer in terms of
instead of like isolation from you know
this is like system calls of Linux and
stuff like that you're just like one
more layer up of its isolating the parts
of kubernetes that you don't want to
interact I think the interesting thing
too about namespaces and you can correct
me if I'm wrong Jesse but my
understanding is if you delete the
namespace it cleans everything up so
from a CI perspective it's nice you
don't have to worry about you know a
pipeline might have 10 or 15 steps all
creating in spawning containers so the
fact that you can just with one API call
wipe all that out and not worry about
leaving artifacts around on the system
is really nice at least from an
integration standpoint probably also it
means you you're less likely to
accidentally wipe off something you
shouldn't be wiping off yeah that's
genius actually I didn't think of that
as a feature it's like a hidden feature
yes yeah I didn't know that was a thing
I'm actually not really excited about it
that's cool credit credit goes to Kelsey
because he's the one that told me to
that's what I should be doing here
coworker cuz he hates our hello
excellent umm sooo now I'm also just
curious like you said that for using
drone you write a docker compose file
what is the developers like experience
like women they use drone sure
I mean drone supports a lot of different
workflows but I think the most
interesting is you know drone uses like
I said a superset of docker compose and
in many ways behaves like docker compose
so you can actually run your build
locally just by running drone exec and
it'll spin up you know let's say you're
using docker for Mac it'll spin up and
run your build in isolation locally so
gone are the days where you're pushing
to your CI server seeing it fail
updating your yeah mo pushing you know
in kind of rinse and repeat doing that
over and over and banging your head
against the wall I've done that so yeah
I think it starts with that and uh a lot
of individuals really like that that
workflow so then when you push to
something like you know github or
bitbucket or get lab drone supports many
different providers
right now everything gets in queued and
drone will pull down the builds on to
one or many machines and execute the
build by interacting directly with the
docker host spinning up those containers
and so the next thing is you have a
level of determinism because the build
that you executed from the command line
on your machine runs the exact same way
in your CI environment on your servers
nice I think it's it's time to go a
little bit more into the architecture
you mentioned that it is raining go yay
you also mentioned that it was basically
just like a docker container everything
was running on containers you can write
very easily on kubernetes what are the
other dependencies that you have is
there any other dependencies like I
don't know like what do you do for
storage or communication across
containers sure so in terms of
dependencies the most important thing in
my opinion with drone is that it ships
is a single binary with no hard external
dependencies other than a container
runtime and so that's important because
no one wants to download and install
open source software and then have to
install 10 other pieces of open source
software but that being said you know
using go and you know go makes it really
easy to do abstractions with interfaces
one of the goals is the ship drone with
built-in modules like a queue like
pub/sub like logs streaming but to allow
you to swap those out with something and
only use this buzzword but something
more cloud native so yeah I know right
I'm laughing uh but I think that's you
know and it's one of those terms that's
thrown around a lot and it's kind of
lost a little bit of meaning but for me
what I what I want with something that's
considered cloud native is you know you
install it you install the software
you're running it but you can swap out
modules with things that are gonna scale
that you don't have to worry about so
for example drone ships with an internal
in memory queue but you can use and go
and using interfaces you can swap it out
very easily with Google cloud pub/sub
nice and so I was gonna ask you said
like using go using interfaces is that
using like the car 1.8 plug-in system or
like how are you actually switching out
from
one together so right now we provide
those baked in so right now if you're
using drone you can use the in memory
cue or the cloud pub/sub cue those are
the only two we offer you know maybe
we'll look at the plugins you know it's
a great an interesting new feature so
it's something we'll definitely look
into there are you configuring that
through like an environment variable or
a few environment variables and then
you're good to go and so then we can do
that you know with other modules in
terms of you know you got the cue now
you have logging drone has an in-memory
log multiplexer you can use stackdriver
logging you can do that with the event
bus you can use pub/sub and another goal
is maybe using kubernetes as the backend
instead of in memory or local docker
nice and once you start doing once
you're able to basically break that I'm
gonna use the word monolith that
monolith that you mentioned that he has
like one single static binary built with
go into more pieces I guess that you're
also thinking about the fact that you
can scale some of the pieces independent
of the rest what are your plans on that
yeah I may think that's the goal is is
letting the developer choose pick and
choose what they want to scale or maybe
as drone grows it can kind of grow with
them by leveraging Google cloud and the
services it provides I'm curious about
Jessi's opinion on the definition of
cloud native because I know that she has
opinions of this so what is cloud native
for you I was actually just gonna joke
that if you say that one more time
Eric Brewers gonna show up here blonde
lady
yeah it's a such a buzzword I think that
it's just honestly anything that you can
deploy in the cloud easily which is a
lot of things and I think people just
kind of throw that around but also
things that are built into tools that
are the cloud like using pub/sub using
integrations into google cloud itself is
super cloud native but yeah I feel like
a salesperson right now I think we need
to take it one step further I think
that's what cloud native always said it
one more time sorry it should be I think
it's all about integrating with those
built in services that Google cloud
platform or you know maybe you know
other providers have to offer to give
you that extra scalability and
maintainability and I wish we were more
strict with the term so that's kind of
how I use it do you look at a torso from
perspective of it's it's an elastic
right if you build certain apps in
certain ways like they're very hard to
scale because they might have
dependencies on other things if you look
at things like tool factor apps that
kind of stuff I think of that as well
when I think cloud native like I've
built my apps such that if it lives in
the cloud I can have 1,000 servers I
can't have 2,000 I could have 10 it
doesn't matter yeah and the scalability
of it in the fact that you can tear it
down spin it up a lot of that I think
comes from containers but being able to
just like clean slate just start from
nothing and go from everything is huge
so last time we talked about drone here
on the podcast was because it was a cool
thing of the week which was because the
newer times they created is it a plugin
for drone so you can deploy stuff
directly to App Engine and container
engine correct yes so drone has a really
nice plug-in system where every step in
the pipeline is a container and that
includes
plugins themselves so writing plugins is
as simple as putting a bash script in a
container so they can be you know really
any language and there's a really low
barrier to entry so the New York Times
created a number of plugins including
kubernetes plugins and
actually has probably about five or six
different kubernetes plugins that work
with kubernetes in different ways some
more simple and some more advanced so
what is the whole idea behind this it
means that I can basically have my llamo
file that you were mentioning at the
beginning and at some point to say
whenever it isn't you change my repo
this is gonna call drones gonna create a
new image in your deployment yeah
correct so it'll you know they're using
we have plug-ins for Google container
registry so in the case of the New York
Times they're pushing to Google
container registry and add a simple
plug-in to do that and then once it was
in the registry the use of kubernetes
plug-in and a spec file and they use
that to automatically push the new image
to kubernetes and auto deploy it to a
number of different instances and I've
even seen teams where they were
deploying pool requests so they would I
- yep go test it and so you can do some
really interesting things there there's
a lot of interesting options well from
those plugins like that and you were
talking about having the pub/sub
integration are there any plans going
forward to be more integrated with
google cloud platform
what's the plans there I think ideally
you know all those different modules we
talked about which is queuing which is a
eventing logging those are all common
with a CI system you'll find them in any
CI system and I would love to be able to
kind of hot swap out those with the you
know Google cloud platform features and
one of the biggest ones is I want to be
able to launch builds on kubernetes
itself so instead of interacting
directly with the docker daemon we can
use the kubernetes scheduler Onis to
launch builds so there's been a bunch of
announcements there's been office of
cool stuff going on would have been some
highlights for you from the conference I
think one of the biggest highlights was
the community summit which gave us a
chance to kind of connect with a lot of
other members in the community
open-source developers and you know get
some insight into the the vision behind
Google cloud and I think as an
open-source maintainer the the thing I
want most is or look forward most is
Google's commitment to
you know I think it's it's awesome that
kubernetes is being developed in the
open and given to the CN CF Foundation
and I'm really interested to see how
much further Google can take that you
know it's an open source developer I
want to integrate with Google but I want
to integrate you know I want to make
sure I'm not locking customers in so I'm
really interested to see how Google will
take you know open this to a next level
in its cloud that was a highlight for me
on my keynote we were like yeah we want
to be open we want to have you land here
we want to have you able to leave but
you know we want to take our chances on
the fact that we're just gonna be the
best place for you to stay and that's it
that's a philosophy that's definitely
near and dear to my heart and yeah
similar question but for Jessie you've
been here the the conference also three
days already what was your favorite
moment ever I guess I have to so my
favorite moment was that the keynote
today was all about like open source and
being open and I obviously loved that
stuff but then I liked the announcement
that earth gave with regard to the
security tip for verifying the bios of
the servers I think that like it's
really cool that Google has this
opportunity since we control the
hardware to do that which not a lot of
people have and super dope yeah we
interviewed cornelius willis and neil
mueller from from google cloud marketing
team exactly about that and we were able
to actually touch one of the type those
titan tips i tried putting one in my ear
cool well we're sort of almost running
out of time but is there anything else
we haven't talked about that you want to
mention before we wrap things up
regarding drone or cloud native or cloud
native or maybe all the planet is or
cloud next server list just getting
[ __ ] one there I I think the only thing
maybe worth mentioning that I'm really
excited about is you know I mentioned
that we were taking all these components
and modules in drone and extending them
and actually pulling them out of drone
and the cool thing is as we do that it
gives you the ability to compose your
own CI system so you can actually you
know if you've ever had the you know
wanted to scratch your own itch and
build that CI system but you didn't want
to build your own Q your own message bus
your own log or inter integrate with
docker integrate with kubernetes your
own yamo format you can actually pick
and choose those modules and compose
your own in a surprisingly small amount
of code and all of these code is as we
said open source and welcome slash drone
slash strong yes perfect cool and that's
the perfect place with people to get
involved they should just go to the
github yeah absolutely
blog tons of issues just rating what
about you Jesse anything else you'd like
to add that's all yeah great well thank
you so much both of you for taking the
time out of your cloud next experience
to share your experience with us
this was fun thanks thanks thank you an
enormous thank you to Brad and Jesse for
joining us Brad a great conversation
about CI CD systems containers Jesse
always a delight to have on the podcast
really interesting stuff I really like
testing and testing infrastructure and
making sure that people do that sort of
stuff
obviously I think a lot of us too but
like having those infrastructure tools
available to people as open-source
products means that we can all build
really good systems yeah also the
explanation on namespaces I actually did
not know much about it so that was very
interesting okay so let's go with a
question of the week and the question of
the week comes from this guy that came
get a podcast t-shirt from a podcast
booth at cloud next his name is Rakesh
Rakesh junkie I hope I pronounced your
name correctly I like you misspelled
your name in the email you sent me but
anyway so his question is like okay so
what is protocol buffers and why should
we all start using it yeah what is
pretty buff so it is another open source
project that came from Google
has actually been around for a long time
what you can basically take from it is
it's an IDL it's an interface definition
language so you write these profiles and
from those profiles you're able to
basically take the data that is dipped
to find in those profiles and send it
across the wire in in a variety of
different languages and it's a binary
format that goes across the way it's
nice and small very performant and super
super cool that way the nice thing is
it's contract first so you're writing
this interface definition language your
sender and receiver both have an
understanding of exactly the data they
should be getting and receiving so
that's hugely powerful but it also gives
you nice things like versioning so if
your data changes you don't have to
worry about it as much between the
sender and receiver and do all sorts of
fun stuff like that yeah just to give an
idea of how important this thing is we
use it at Google for virtually
everything up whatever we encode
anything in files it's always protocol
buffers wherever we sending data over
the network it's always protocol buffers
so it is basically we do not use JSON
internally that much instead we use
protocol buffers so you can see it like
a more efficient and easier to
collaborate way of sending data around
if you're gonna play with protocol
buffers I would definitely say have a
look at the G RPC project yes it is the
default serialization and basically like
core interface to G RPC we have two
episodes that we've talked about it on
episode number 15 we had a room tour
wall who's the PM on it yep and we also
talked with Brandon Phillips from core
OS who talked about how they use it
internally as well yeah and they use it
a lot so definitely well worth listen
you can use protocol buffers on their
own but I think combined with your RPC
it's just a really nice fit yeah and
basically G RPC what its gonna do it's
gonna give you so if protocol buffers
defines the messages G RPC defines the
operations that we see even sends those
messages pretty much pretty much kind of
a way of saying it and since we're
talking about proto buffers there's also
another cool project that I really like
and I discovered not that long ago it's
called flatbuffers of course you've
heard about flatbuffers cuz video game
players like video game designers love
it yes I have heard about buffers so
flat buffers are literally a slightly
different way of serializing data up and
down the pipe
still has an interface definition
language but the thing that makes it
different is
the data can be accessed directly
without having to parse anon packet on
the other end yeah so basically the the
way I see flatbuffers is that in
protocol buffers you need to decode the
home message to get any of the data
inside in flatbuffers you can just like
whenever you need that piece of data you
accesses directly which means that
you're kind of doing like lazy decoding
and if you have a lot of information and
you want to just like start the game now
hmm you can do it yeah so you get just
different pros and cons on each down on
which side you get the the performance
hit on they both work for the cool thing
is if you're using Java C you can use
swap buffers and you can use protocol
buffers up to you awesome well I think
that's gonna wrap up another episode
today francisc are you heading off I
think you're still going to graphic on
China yes I'll being gopher cantina
April 15th and 16th and I'm planning to
do some other things around still not
have decided so I will not announce it
yet and afterwards I'll be on my way to
New York first week of April up in your
internal meeting so probably I'm going
to be planning some don't meet ups over
kubernetes meetup stuff like that what
about you so as I said before I'm
heading off to Vancouver
I've just had confirmed that I will be
speaking at the Vancouver unity Meetup
talking about game server is actually
running on kubernetes which is loads and
loads of fun and then I will also be
talking at the polyglot meetup on the
6th as well and Vancouver redoing arrow
favourite Simon Says talking about G RPC
and Crippen he's strangely enough oh
yeah but after that later in April
eastcoast game conference and vector
I'll be there both places as well again
talking about kubernetes and game
servers I'm having loads of fun there
well I think it's time to say goodbye so
thanks again one more week and there's
seven two weeks in a row thank you for
taking the time to record these amazing
episode with me and thank you all out
there for listening yeah and Francis
thank you for joining me once again and
we'll see you all next week see y'all
next week
you